o
[Music]
p
good
w
it's already on hello hello so uh we
listen to a recording of birds and old
uh riverbed in VAV uh and in this part I
I wanted to acknowledge this wonderful
creatures and their body that
contributed uh uh the collection of
History uh of a museum of natural
history uh
so today I'm going to tell you the story
about the former Su treatment Farm in
VAV uh this is me I'm katar from B VAV
you can see me with my Turbo ears uh on
my head those are
microphones and um like this is very
important for me in my curatorial
practice to listen to uh so like
recording uh the fields was the very uh
important part of my research here on a
picture you see also Daniel broek he's a
he's a sound and curator and sound
artist from the collective called canti
spati and together with me we have been
record uh the so-called fields of
regeneration uh from from
2021 here you see the snapshot of this
amazing uh place the place that I will
tell you about tonight so again I'm
kataro and today I will tell you about
the culture of
regeneration uh for many years I used to
run uh the gallery called Design Gallery
this is a one of our four galleries uh
in the structure of bav
RAV uh and the culture of regeneration
is a result U of uh my experience uh
from uh from this from this Gallery so
culture of regeneration this is
um this is like a curatorial program uh
at the inter intersection of design art
uh and Science and it features a variety
actions like walks exhibition Labs
lectures residency listening sessions
and uh study visits and my challenge
is to rethink the concept of resilient
resilience in the city and uh like how
to integrate humans and their
infrastructure to Nature so culture of
regeneration uh has three program lines
uh resilience that would be the first
one and it's based on the idea of
sanatorium I will touch this uh subject
in a moment H the other one is the pr
VAV Continuum based on the material
culture of the city and nature-based
solutions based on the knowledge
gathered from among others the S Farm
Technology but before I will start to uh
explore the subject I will tell you a
little bit more about the institutions
uh about the institution uh this will be
of course a short section uh of our
activities uh so Bev RAV this is a
cultural institution uh financed by City
of RAV those are four venues connected
by a program presenting Contemporary Art
and Design uh in its new sometimes
surprising manifestation the director of
bav is ma buo I have this privilege that
from March this year I am the deputy
director from program and educ
education but as I told you from 2009 I
used to run one of the four Galler is
called design uh this is uh the space of
the gallery uh you can see that the
gallery is situated in the very um uh
special place in RAV in the very heart
of RAV next to uh time Hall and the
gallery was established in
1993 uh previously the space housed a
gallery and even before there was a
Furniture uh shop uh but and before the
war the building
uh did not exist so from 2009 when I
started to work at the gallery I took a
different uh operating model and over
years uh with a group of extraordinary
extraordinary uh companions uh we have
developed a model of a gallery that is
friendly uh curious about the knowledge
but uh which also offers a stimulating
physical experience uh those those were
days of labs sessions and collective
learning instead of exhibitional uh
program so uh for us um all those years
we have been mainly process based uh
Gallery uh our motto has been less
showing more action here you can see
Alicia patosa one uh of artist and
designer that uh worked with us uh for
the sake of the exhibition she just
moved her Studio into the gallery and
for the whole time she was like building
up the exhibition involving audience
showing their the her practice her
skills and telling about the embodied
knowledge which is very important
especially in case of being a
poist so another uh like something that
is special for so what was special for
us that is questioning the habits of how
our audience is uh uh uh is uh taking
part in the art show like here you you
can see the exhibition called the book
the book club and the exhibition
presented books uh but uh what is
special and why I want to uh emphasize
is that we put a large uh bed in the uh
in the center of the gallery uh and let
people just you know to perform with the
book to let L down and you know to spend
you know some time uh together in this
uh in this way so uh I want to tell uh a
little bit more about three light
motives uh from our program and first
would be the anti-consumerism
and uh
like uh like for us it was uh something
that we started with this is the the
first exhibition called goodbye design
and uh what was important for us uh is
um we wanted to like show the people
what is the way to be as a part of the
exhibition to be uh that that is based
on the participation not uh consumption
and uh many uh projects of us addressed
the problem of uh unfair distributed
consumption in the world where the few
have much and the many have little and I
think it's very important uh in
discussion about the design and um like
how design let people be more uh
Consciousness about uh the the world
about the uh like and how to how to show
that design is not only connected to the
sales Market but it's more about uh
solving some social uh problems
and another thing is to perform design
objects so we are this kind of gallery
that we are not showing study objects
but more uh trying to involve people to
perform like to try uh and to have some
fun and some experience with project
that uh we were presenting and for
example this is a
Balo uh concept By Conrad d bitsky uh
and there there was a set of few it sys
uh uh like for example thermop for on
inhalator and that was the last project
that we perform before pandemia started
and of course we had to like change a
bit our directions but still like having
this idea of like performing design
instead uh presenting them this is
something that is very uh very uh
important uh for us and
another um perspective uh that was uh
the act of lying down and we've noticed
that many of our projects involve our
audience to lay down uh which is uh
quite exceptional because like public
sphere is uh asking us to move to stand
to sit but never lay down and uh in the
future in the past in the in the past uh
like we have like a different
choreography in the public sphere so
it's like trying to show that laying
down might be a public uh position uh
was always uh something that I was
interested in and then in 2009 uh we
started with the project called Jia that
would be liery in English and this is a
space that uh people can use during the
daytime and uh this is the space that
people can lay down to relax uh and to
use it in a way that is needed and uh
like like many of our Furnitures like
like LED people to to use it in a very
relaxative way uh but uh we did more
like for example like watering like
having like a glass of water for example
was uh always uh something that was a
part of this project listening
activities this is something that you
maybe already noticed uh is very
important important tool uh to connect
with the audience of course media
exploring like to get some critiques
over the technology how do we use them
how can we use them in the future but
also practicing like we have this idea
of the space that is open to the public
that is uh not only uh a a place where
we are presenting something we are
showing something we are dealing with
something but also to ask people to use
the space uh in their uh
purposes but uh what is even more
important is uh and we imagined that the
gallery is a agent of stimulating
senses and uh I was very inspired by um
uh by the by the notion that smell is
something that is very delicate and uh
this is the last thing uh like uh if you
like if you want to avoid being a cons
consumer you have to be very aware of uh
this uh this sense because somehow this
is the last uh tool that we can fight
with the
consumerism uh and uh like could
elaborate it more but maybe during the
the presentation I will uh come back to
this subject as well so uh Z was based
on this idea of
sanatorium uh which was very important
for me to create this uh uh red
definition of uh resilience in the
city and maybe I will tell you a little
more more about the con the context so
VAV uh used to it those are previous
names of of the city is the capital of
lower salesia and this is the region
reach in sanatorium
tradition and among others uh there is
one typology of space that is very
inspiring those are mineral water pump
houses and for me uh they are very uh
inspiring in term of critical uh Urban
spaces those were spaces where people
could come and drink water like gather
around the water intake and also um like
to to spend some time because the the
other accompaning activities would be
reading somehow a team playing uh having
some
treatments uh reading newspapers and
also you know to do some physical uh
treatments as well but also uh those
water uh pump rooms are very
inspiring they were very inspiring for
me as a typology not even particular
spaces but a as a typology uh to show
that other non-human perspective here we
see the um pictures um uh taken by Anna
arova we went together for artistic
Journey to the LA salesian sanatoriums
and on this picture you can see the ion
deposition and some mineral
mineralization on the stone and let me
to uh think about the other non-human
perspective and to see
the human uh material culture from the
different material uh mineral
perspective uh but after the pandemia or
during the pandemia we had to change uh
the mode that we were
operating and uh we imagined that
Gallery as a sanatorium is very powerful
idea but uh maybe going to the nature uh
is something that is even uh more um
more important and this is how we
started to uh like we moved our
activities into the uh nature and uh
here like we finally found uh the proper
space uh we called it the fields of
regeneration and we started you know
some treatments some activities with
artists and designers just there here
you can see some people
uh playing with reedbed in this
sanatorium uh
flavor but finally uh it occurred to us
that our fields of regeneration used to
be former sewi treatment
farm and now you can see uh on the map
that it's a huge organism in the body of
the city uh this is the they're marked
blue so it's like a 12 hectars uh
already and uh the this amazing uh
organism is connected those are Fields
but also to forest rinsky forest and oo
soobitsky
forest and here you can see the aerial
photo of this area it was taken by kater
kovalski his amazing um artist who is
actually flying over the
landscape and he took some uh took some
photos of this huge organism and for
example here here you can see that this
right angle that is uh it's really hard
to find one in the nature but uh shows
that uh this uh this organism is quite
um like that there is a the mar Paradox
in this uh organism and here on the map
you can see how it used to look like uh
during the German times so here is breau
uh the the the city it used to be
smaller than it this at the moment and
here you can see the huge uh fields that
were connected in the late uh uh 80 80s
in 19th century to the to the city as a
part of the canalization system so the
idea was to put the switch through this
main Canal here and to distribute the
switch into the poers and then using the
like Natural Forces uh using soil using
using read Bats the seage was uh
purified and then uh it might go to the
river um I started with uh people's
story because it was pandemia so
archives were closed so it was very uh
like amazing from the beginning that I
had to deal with uh some memories and
with some oral stories about the about
this uh those Fields but later on I
realized that the story is really well
documented but little experience uh when
I was talking to the people like there
is one thing that is very uh well known
that this uh those fields were very
stinky and this is the only memory that
uh people from BR of already haded about
uh the
place uh here on the on the uh uh
project on the blueprint you can see
that Designer like really fit into
the uh field
terrain uh and did the job uh very very
smart you using some kind of
nature-based
solutions and uh on those fields there
was not only a Swit treatment Farm but
also some some parts were used as
Agriculture and for example you can see
that on this picture that uh seage Farm
were very you know popular at the time
like the soil was fertilized with sewage
somehow and it happened the same in
braslau and for example uh the willow
tobacco uh or the sugar beads were
cultivated
there of course that system is still
like the idea is still working on in
some part of of the world but here in
Europe we have like we change our
perspective and something that we could
call the hygienic uh imagination so at
the moment we can imagine ourself that
we are
using um the waste for example from uh
from animals but uh it's really hard for
us to believe that somebody used to uh
used to uh use domestic seage as a
fertilizer for the
soil but uh uh those S treatment Farms
they were very popular in prusia
especially mostly because of the law uh
that ask people to like official to
manage the seage before it was uh put
into the rivers and for example like uh
there are like many of them in brow like
the in in Berlin around Berlin many
relics of them and I started to visit
visited uh them uh from
2022 uh I visited already two one is H
felda you uh in bin you call it relf
Felder and to this year we had a visit
uh at uh the relf Felder called B and if
you do not know this amazing landscape
uh please try to get some uh asban and
just to enjoy the pure nature
uh in the city
area uh so the whole radial system in
Berlin was set by James hogre uh with
the help ideological help of rudol
vhof uh but Edward Viba used to be a
great absentee of this um Swit project
mostly because he didn't event the idea
how to treat the seage uh but later
later on when he he was working with uh
seage in G in Danish he already used
that technology as
a result of the whole project for seage
and for canalization of of gin and here
you can see on the right there is um uh
relics of former s treatment Farm uh
that was built by him and he's uh this
is like um
model of it that you can see that this
is like real AR like architectural and
there is a real Engineers work uh with
that and this experience Edward Viber
used to uh design canalization and
system and switch Management in BR in
brow uh here you can see the map that
was prepared by uh Kaya
Geva our graphic designer ER and uh this
is the map for audience for for our
public to explore the VAV s treatment
Farm the fields of regeneration
so-called uh and uh Kaa put the old
River Band to the map just to show that
the river was uh moved uh in the late
18th century but uh this is important to
know because in those parts of those
fields water still appear somehow what
is described by the scientist uh as a
water
memory and uh another you know very
important uh subject of culture of
regeneration is the Continuum which is
especially important in the such a town
like uh VAV like brlo VAV mostly because
the tradition like a local tradition of
the city was uh completely destroyed
destroyed during the war and post-war uh
propaganda and you know like searching
for the continuity is very somehow
important for us and I think I am the
first like I am a represent
representative of first generation that
is really seeking you know the former uh
tradition uh of of the of the place of
the city and you know to show like to
like to investigate what last during
that uh during that
time uh and of course like nature is you
know the
best example of continuation of
continuity and here you can see amazing
character from fields of regeneration
from this seage treatment farm this is
the little bird called the uh black
throat uh it's a little really little uh
bird but singing a in amazing way and it
was seen already in the very beginning
of 20th century so we can see that you
know like orology and somehow the
discourse around uh nature can Thrive
the systemic change the like the the
change involving you know different
nations different uh Pol polit
politics but Continuum it's also about
that that this project like it's it's
not ending like of course the exhibition
has ended but the project is still on
and we are acting we are performing we
are investigating in different uh part
of the seasons with different season
with in every part in every part of the
day and a year and Continuum here is
also about the community around this
subject uh as my uh research report Ed
like the whole uh
environmental uh frenzy about this
organism started already in
1970s and they were like amazing people
that were really interested in the
future of this uh space and one time we
gathered together on those fields uh
just to see how do we see that uh
landscape what is the difference in our
perspective uh how can we Explore More
having this um this different uh
perspective here on the photograph you
can see M tap pishek among others
Alexandra gero M Novak many other
amazing activists that used to work for
the uh for those
fields but continum is also uh about the
way that the landscape is changing and
here you can see see the photographs of
the same um part of the those fields
shooted by Anton
knwa uh the uh the picture on the left
is taken it was taken in
2009 and uh the other picture was taken
after
2015 uh when the Swit treatment Farm
stopped to operate I didn't mention that
but the uh the swi treatment Farm
started in
1881 exactly in June 28th the first
portion of sewage was put into the those
fields but uh the treatment was uh ended
in 2015 so for almost
134 years uh the treatment was uh on uh
first cleaning you know the waste the
German waste and then the Polish waste
so it's you know something that uh is uh
quite important in its
biography so right now we have like a 12
100 hectars of so-called nature culture
it's a construct showing that uh you
know it's a place of spontaneous um
action like nature actions but also you
can see like the relics of uh human um
uh human design
and as we
found what I tell you already that there
is a great regeneration regenerative
potential not only for humans but also
for itself like the fields were really
contaminated uh with sewage there was a
lot of amount water but also uh many
heavy metals and we know that the soil
manage you know to to clean it so uh so
like
those fields are regenerative for us but
also they are regenerative for uh
itself and uh there is like amazing
technical relics that uh can show us
like the archaeology of hyro uh
infrastructure uh here you can see
amazing Pump Station actually I think
that maybe it might be a
great uh space for some some some kind
of cultural events but also to uh to
give some information like a info point
for people uh that want to go into the
fields uh those pum State we already had
one concert uh that we did together with
kti spati Collective we know that
acoustic is amazing and this F station
was uh powered by steam in the very
beginning so this is why you can see
this chimney but later on after two
decades uh
uh it was run by diesel engine and as
people believed uh it was the first
example of uh diesel engine uh in the
lower
cesia here are some uh blueprints that I
found in the
archives so uh what is the amazing thing
about them is that those Wetlands were
created as a result of irrigation with
the seage so like in the very original
idea they were supposed to be very
efficient efficient and that's why the
pump station was put it there just to
pump the uh the amount water that uh
that was uh not needed there but uh
because the city grown so easily after
the war and uh the usage of water was uh
uh was Rising the the SE treatment Farm
caus in like take it anymore so this is
how the wetlands were created there and
I found it really uh amazing this is you
know this one of this Paradox that uh we
know that wetlands are very critical
Landscapes uh critical ecosystems on the
world but uh they are like shrinking
because of the humans
activities but this one uh was created
uh in the very close
uh
um like because of the human physiology
somehow so this is something that is
very unique uh for this uh for this
ecosystem and unfortunately after after
2015 uh when uh the Swit treatment was
ended and the Swit went to the other
like modern chemical treatment uh plant
uh no sewage and no water is going there
anymore so we are like seeing that uh
everything there is drying at the
moment and in this moment of change we
are like uh uh we want to be there with
artists designers scientists
environmentalists we started you know
very in a very organic way it was
pandemic time so we just you know spent
you know some time together on the fresh
air the first uh artist was ukash RN who
started to take some pictures there and
then you know like we started to field
record and uh after one week what week
after week uh like many like other
people like were uh joining us and do
you know like many interesting things
there and many interesting projects
I just want to mention to people from
that time on the left this is Alexandra
gko she managed to have like she she
wrote in a PhD about uh the history and
the
system and she was she she gave me like
a lot of support in the very beginning
and on the right there is y Anna navro
and she's a person that uh like she
spent all her childhood
nearby and she's a chairwoman uh of
the
uh like she's a she's a chair chairwoman
of a of a group of people living on uh
on this settlement next to uh those
fields and like it was completely
different uh um knowledge because it was
knowledge that was embodied that was
knowledge that was based on her
experience and experience of people that
used to live there
and uh speaking about the knowledge like
uh for us like this intersection of art
design and science uh is given us a lot
of opportunity to challenge the
knowledge production somehow and when we
were setting up our exhibition that uh
there was natural
inventory uh going on uh this time so
like scientists were accounting for
example plants living there and we did
the same but in a completely different
way like for example here uh those are
uh bottles with per perfumes made uh
by made by Monica Opa and those are
plants the same plants but you know like
uh with with a smell and sometimes even
in those flacons you could find some
story about those fields that was uh
that was in like ful like filled that uh
that battle and for example uh again
like orist like we counting uh Birds
living there but what we did is
to um to like to listen and to record
the whole
season uh of birds living there so this
is you know like completely different
knowledge production and I think you
know like this uh Art institution
cultural institution have this huge
opportunity to collaborate with science
this is not something that is against
you know this uh classical tools but
something that let us explore and to
communicate uh something to the public
in a slightly different and more
empathic uh
way we also did some scenario design and
it was never a about how to plan the
future because back then we knew that
the situation is very complicated and we
are not able just you know to and we
were not ready just to figure out what
would happen with those fields but we
like having like playing with this idea
of scenario with centrala group we
wanted to explore our imagination how
can we imagine the nature in the city uh
what would be uh the future of it if
they supposed to be re renature like Rew
or maybe it should be a space for you
know spontaneous nature actions or maybe
we thought we should think more about
utilitarian way that we can use somehow
and collaborate with this uh with this
organism and to light motive because the
the project is so uh bold and you know
like uh have many
directions uh but like to like light
motives that I want you to remember that
is that what we are trying to see is the
seasonal embodiment something that we
like called like seasonal embodiment and
this is um about following natural
calendar we know that those season
change they're quite steady at the
moment of course they're in a somehow
changing but they're still quite steady
and we just want to follow that uh and
to gain some knowledge
uh like stried from this uh
experience and another light motive
would be this socialization so uh it's
letting us you know
to to make some horizontal situation
when expert can uh spend some time with
uh with the public and to explore more
uh in this uh nice situation not you
know talking exca right I'm doing at the
moment but you know in more involving
way and another one is uh what we are
trying to learn out of it so that would
be the prototype in new social services
and for example we really think about
the natural reserve that is going to
happen there somehow this is what was
stated by the mayor of the city but also
maybe how to give some addition
additional uh services like for example
this
idea of sanatorium idea of Jia but move
to those fields and you know to treat
some Urban neurosis and people that is
searching you know for some other
natural treatments uh that that the
space is just perfect for
that and uh at the moment we start like
another project we still don't know uh
how it will happen you are like the
first audience that I'm sh in with uh
this uh this project is called
laboratory for happiness research after
Comfort uh and you know this is quite
unique project that is run by get
Institute Vara uh Bosa is the curator of
it and this is a a five cultural
institution in Poland working with
artist uh designers uh the public and
the scientists and the business uh field
under somehow a prototype uh that would
change something in our city uh in term
of losing Comfort somehow losing Comfort
is something that we have to be ready
for like we have to share what has left
and so and we have to
be um like like really uh strict about
that that uh our energy resources are
you know like in not very bad position
at the moment so maybe we have to find
something to change uh our habits uh to
share the comfort with with others not
only humans so in that matter we decided
to work with uh with soil because this
is something that we already uh
researched dur during this project
fields of regeneration and we thought
that maybe this is time for another
chapter not only to talk and to explore
about the fields of regeneration but to
take some kind of knowledge and to check
how can we scale it uh in a different
part of the
city uh and here on the picture you can
see the sketch of Christina yandre kashm
this is a Ryon uh this is a re
rym uh this is the part of the re that
you cannot see but you it's very
strength and it's very resilient and
this is how the re uh is very resilient
plant mostly because of the rism and uh
that is uh the way that the plant is
connecting to each other and we thought
that maybe that would be you know a
great
uh that would be you know great uh like
to imagine that our city might work just
like that so we imagine this is how we
started with this project with this some
kind of pre-assumptions that city is a
living uh organism that is inhabited not
only by people and uh it is somehow
nature culture so it's not you know that
we are like uh like having this part
that are uh about nature and some parts
that are about our infrastructure that
somehow we have to like find another way
uh to combine those uh two aspects of
course we want to work like and we want
to prototype something for for the city
that uh uh is circular uh and to accept
dirty processes this is something that
we learned out of heel Felder as well
you know that we have to always uh think
about uh our waste and uh we are very
you know happy to talk about vernacular
pre-industrial knowledge and
Technology uh like for example switch
treatment Farm something that is
uh you know like this is like really old
technology that uh for us at the moment
could be uh understood as a you know
some kind of archaeology of nature based
Solutions and the context would be also
the scenario made by centrala that was
the one of the three scenarios I already
told you about and this scenario was
showing the possible future of those
fields that are utilitarian
and from the very beginning people
didn't like that because we don't we do
not like think about uh the nature that
we can use it somehow and F of course we
have to find
another dictionary like like another
word to describe this relation but uh we
think that maybe you know that
infrastructure because in this scenario
the idea was to use that like former in
infrastructure to produce soil
uh or to to have you know some some
ponds uh with uh
hotan that could be then uh placed in
the
city and uh right now we still don't
know how we going to operate but we
already had some field visits so we
started with City composter in VAV this
is the really nice place where uh the
leaves and the so-called green waste is
puted there and and the soil production
is starting to to like they start the
soil produ production and this is very
uh for me future thinking because like
uh and I think you no this is quite nice
Ser quite nice service because uh like
uh the soil that is produced there might
be taken by Resident
residents we also uh uh research on
composers that are uh in our parks and
then we went to Berlin we visited
floating
University if you do not know that space
I high highly recommend it to you this
is a
space um nature culture space near
templehof run by a great
Collective uh that is producing uh you
know like completely different like like
the they are you know like producing
different embodied
knowledge and we also went to the
princes and Garten in Berlin where we
found you know like many like we were
discuss and CH like U talking with
people uh and like discussing their
experience in soil production and
fertilizers uh in a
city so uh like next week uh we will
meet together with centrala again there
is Spirit ficial waiting for us from
floating Berlin in uh in VAV uh and we
will go on to discuss about the idea of
urban uh living soil system how can we
uh like put things together and maybe to
to find some prototypes that would be
addressing the idea of Healthy Living
soil and thank you very much uh for your
presence here and if if you have some
questions we still have some time so I'm
open to for the
[Applause]
discussion so any
questions
uh well not not this one in uh in
breau like the the oldest uh the oldest
switch treatment farm that I already
checked is was in bulau it's bavet
nowaday and I found some trucks from
16th century uh that they were already
treated Sage on those fields and using
as a in the agricultural way you know as
a
fertilizer
uh there is uh there is one in England
I've never been there but I was told
that there is one still operating and
the technology is uh use it in a very
like domestic way like people are very
into having this natural uh treatment um
area spots uh around their uh
homes but uh in India for example in
kolkota there is one amazing huge like
huge
Wetlands run by uh local people for many
many decades many uh generation people
used to work on that and uh it's still
something that I haven't experience uh I
was maybe I will try to go there next
year to visit it there and you know this
is like a huge uh Swit treatment Farm
still working and
uh I know know that only from from books
and from some articles but the idea is
that the waste is going uh to those
Wetlands there the the sage is treated
then the water is go to the water goes
to the fish ponds there are some
agriculture there and then those
vegetables those fishes come back to
Kolkata to the stomach of uh its
residents and then again to the field so
have like this amazing amazing glob I
think this is something uh that our
Western imagination is very into at the
moment that we really uh like not this
is not only an imagination this is
actual a policy that we want to uh get
our cities circular but uh I think that
you know many countries uh especially on
the south that we uh can use their
experience their knowledge and treat us
a real experts in
that
yes
yeah
actually we haven't established such
archives but it's a it's a great plan
for me for next year you know to like
put uh things into one uh repository to
let other artists and designers uh to to
use it in their uh art so not yet but
because you know like everything was a
bit you know spontaneous and you know
very organic but yeah we are thinking
about about
that
well um like I know that there are some
uh projects that are sorry that are
already in uh I was like talking to the
uh sustain sustainable department at our
Municipal and I know that uh um there
are some Engineers that already the uh
design uh
socalled uh pen uh pen stocks that is
something to let uh like like to to to
quit the water outflow from from the
fields just you know like the water
retention would be helpful at the at the
moment because as I told you like the
whole or like the whole infrastructure
was designed not to keep the water there
but to to pump uh like purified uh water
into the river so right now we have to
like reverse that and maybe to put that
uh pen stocks you know just to have more
water inana and m River and I don't and
I know that they want to somehow
establish uh some um retention next to
this uh River all River
bent so there are yeah there are some
you know projects that are already on
this Municipal level that is trying to
uh like to keep some water
there
yes m
yeah yeah it would be you know it would
be amazing plan actually and I know that
here on the HRI felda this is how they
uh they achieved some water from a
different seage treatment plan that
purified water is going to this H felda
area but in VAV uh I think you know
there we made some wrong decisions in
the past and they put the uh uh like uh
This Modern uh switch treatment plant in
the other like on the other part like on
the other band of the river so right now
it had to be uh pumped to the fields and
we already know that there is a little
slope of the terrain just you know to
because like those Engineers wanted to
like embrace the Natural Forces natural
gravity forces uh to to leave the water
uh to put the water into the river so
right now you it had to be you know pump
anti- gravit somehow so but I know that
there is uh one scenario that is like
this this scenario is is still on
somehow but it will be very difficult
definitely because of the uh
terrain
yes
well this is something that we are
trying to help with like we have an
audience we have the community build
that uh around this this subject already
and uh we are you know trying to like to
negotiate you know those all those uh
sides of this uh uh subject together and
you know to to to discuss that but uh of
course like it's not that easy mostly
because like you know the the hard job
has to be done just
before uh and it's not negotiable like
for example you know having this hyra
engineering at the moment uh but in term
of you know future scenario how we going
to use that how we going to
like use what what a what a what a
strange and bad word for that but how we
going to act in this in those fields
this is something that we are trying to
involve Audience by
ourself
yes
well like uh like from my perspective uh
this is you know like people are walking
and you know like uh like having fun
there but uh this is still you know like
a small group of people I think in a
scale of the
city and uh and still when you know
sometimes in a cup or you know like any
uh any places sometimes I'm there you
know and I'm talking to the people and
I'm just you know like Supernatural way
I'm just you know the subject the fields
are the subject then I always ask people
if have they have any like Memories or
you know like knowledge about it and I
know that still people are like
reflecting this ideas as a something
that is uh that is closed restricted and
uh smelling ugly and I even have one um
because there is a train
tracks uh and uh when you are coming
from poine to VAV you always have to
like uh uh pass those
fields and once I had a conversation
with the guy from the train uh the
conductor and I and I I was talking to
him about the the history of those SE
this those fields and he told me that
any time he's passing those fields that
terrible smell makes him nauseous and I
told him that for my perspective at
least for five years it's not smelly
anymore like when we were trying to work
with Monika Opa under you know this
fragrances from fields we were like
investigating people going you know to
the fields uh like we found like two
particular moments during the daytime
that we can uh smell a little bit you
know the the former smell and it's it
was really hard for us you know like to
to to really get some information what
was the structure of the smell and we
had to base on this memories of people
so I told to the guy and he thought that
it's it's impossible because anytime
he's passing those felds they are so so
stinky so then I realized that smell is
something that is so strong and people
have this smell trauma somehow some this
you know this phantom phantom smell so I
would say that this smelly fields that
would be you know something that is well
known in in in VAV but nothing
else
that help orid to to keep it Val
well uh it was changing actually like I
I started with this idea that we have to
do everything you know to keep uh the
space wet uh but rather right now I I
think that we have to like measure what
is you know what is important in that
matter and maybe we because they are
like 12 hectares at the moment they are
going to be like like uh like only you
know some part of it would be under the
this natural reserve protection but
still it's a huge organism and maybe we
do not need a one policy for uh for this
landscape but you know to to check what
is possible and maybe we could establish
somehow a mosaic of Landscapes there and
you know to see how they react to each
other how they like um establishing
so-called ecotones you know the the
zones between ecosystems that would be
maybe helpful and of course there are
you know flora and FAA that is you know
out from Wetland section so it would be
terrible you know
to um to lose it but uh maybe some
somehow it's also good you know to like
to say yes you know to the adaptation
and to help this organism to adapt to
the other
circumstances but I think you know the
idea that uh we see it as a mosaic and
we Embrace W places where where it is
possible that would be the best solution
that that is my perspective in that uh
in that
matter thank you
yes
yeah
m
thank you very
much thank you thank you very
much yeah you know like uh this is why I
started you know with some
uh some history like a past history
because at the moment the design gallery
is closed because we are like expecting
some kind of renovation of the building
the building is really tired and our
electricity went down somehow so we are
expecting a like a really massive uh
renovation so the gallery is is closed
uh but you know like I I just wanted to
tell that not only because to introduce
myself but also to show that we re we
are really trained into the process
management that we Embrace process that
we are not afraid of it that uh we have
some pre-assumptions as a team of
curators but
um but uh we can deal that we have to
you know like we we don't have a control
under
everything over everything
so yeah you know this is something that
we still like working on and uh we can
learn like you know like curating
landscape that that it is just you
know you know this is like the like for
me it's just you know the the perfect
engagement because it changed the idea
of curating that uh curating has also
something in common with sanatorium idea
because this is something that you are
taken care of so there is still you know
some kind of relation uh in that that
but when when you want to create a
landscape then you have to change uh
your position and you have to be as a
good curator I believe you know some
kind of medium more than uh than the
person that is in charge you know to
decide what will happen
next
yeah but you know I I think you know
like the the working with uh this
environmental work Works they are just
you know like very challenging mostly
because uh it's it's really hard to
predict how the organism like the huge
organism will react for example for you
know any step so like for me it's always
like we have to always decide for some
kind of scenario this is how our our
Modern Life looks like but you know it's
it it would be so perfect if we could
you know like put one step and then if
it doesn't work then you know to change
the strategy
somehow
yes
actually actually we didn't you know put
some steps but I know that that that
would be perfect yeah but maybe we
should find some legal person to help us
how to how to manage that yeah but I was
thinking about that that would be that
would be great you know
to to to keep it you know and to to
preserve it uh as a as a person yeah but
no the like we we haven't started yet
but I'm taking your question as a you
know
Sparkle you are amazing audience and you
know like speaking about Jia like we do
this slightly in a different way this is
something that I already said to Dan
that in Jia we are like work in a more
horizontal
way uh and you know the whole uh space
was designed you know to uh let people
like act more like in living room
situation like a salon situation and
this is something that I'm very into
that it was quite you know stressful for
me to be in this position you know like
a expert and you know have this Dynamic
that I'm you know just here standing
here ex
cathedra so I'm I'm I'm really happy
that we already had this that we had the
chance for this discussion thank you
very
[Applause]
much yeah it's I think it's it's done
time is over I think thank you very
much